in a middle full of books net thing  that's me and my two best friends be  impossible  Northfield holsters yeah bring her over  here no way not worked any better than  that  what do you see you see anyway they're  much prettier and more time with their  girls out there I heard an updated list  comes out of reminding and since I'm  number one  do what I say in YouTube you guys  I'm gorgeous well solution would have to  be brilliant in math and statistics and  considering the size of the dub be  pretty darn tired hey Albert  you dropped your advanced statistics  books then I'm pretty darn I see you  okay if you want to be popular we need  to work on your look something bolded  says  you will be mine that big beat I want to  know what's going on between you and  that I don't know what you're talking  about  because of your massive we beat  Jefferson we are nothing